ich habe sehr lange darüber nachgedacht
ob ich das wieder überhaupt aufnehmen
denn ich bin mir bewusst dass es dazu
führen könnte dass einer von euch auch
die schule abbricht und das ist etwas
was ich nicht verantworten möchte ich
habe mich trotzdem dazu entschieden
dieses risiko einzugehen und nach langer
zeit endlich mal ausführlich darüber zu
reden weil es ein extrem wichtiger
bestandteil meiner geschichte ist und
ich auch nicht aus angst der
öffentlichkeit vorenthalten möchte die
schule abzubrechen war mit sicherheit
die beste entscheidung meines lebens
und warum das so ist und ob das finde
ich auch zu sagen könnte gleich in
diesem video aber kleine spoiler auch
wenn es die beste entscheidung meines
lebens war die schule abzubrechen wäre
es höchst wahrscheinlich die schlimmste
entscheidung in deinem leben wenn du das
auch machen würde ist so jetzt kann mir
keiner anhängen kinder dazu anzustiften
nicht zu brechen
check
[Musik]
ihr wurdet von mir dazu aufgerufen mir
frage auf instagram zu stellen und eine
davon war
hast du in der schule mal alkohol
getrunken extrem brisante frage hier
schon am anfang ich muss sagen ich
glaube einmal und das war der zehnten
klasse beim abschluss und das war
irgendwie ein bier oder so also ja oh
mein gott es geht richtig schlimm weiter
und zwar mit hast du schon mal schule
geschwänzt
was soll ich sagen ja ich glaube jeder
hat mal geschwänzt ich glaube jeder hat
mal geschwänzt und ich wenn ich mich
recht entsinne habe ich paar mal
geschwänzt aber dann wenn dann halt
schon somit entschuldigung so im sinne
von anrufen und sagen hey ammann kommt
nicht ja aber ich habe von leuten gehört
die einfach nicht zur schule gehen und
sich nicht entschuldigen sondern war
halt nicht hingehen und so was also nie
gemacht ihre und jetzt kommen wir zur
frage auf die ich auch schon am anfang
an gegangen bin und die auch den titel
bestimmt und das wäre lohnt es sich voll
abitur zu machen mit vollabitur meinte
person wahrscheinlich allgemeines abitur
da muss ich ganz einfach sagen dass ein
komplett ab auf eure situation ist kann
ich nicht über einen kamm scheren
ich hab mein abi abgebrochen und nur
deswegen bin ich jetzt hier wo ich bin
war hätte ich dieses eine jahr noch mehr
in die schule investiert dann wäre dazu
wahrscheinlich abgefahren und ich hatte
das was ich jetzt erreicht habe wenn
überhaupt erst in ein paar jahren
erreicht also viel später und ich würde
keinem empfehlen die schule abzubrechen
bin ich noch gar keinen abschluss hat
das ist einfach nur dumm ohne jetzt sah
irgendwie noch falsche gedanken bringen
zu wollen ja prächtig folie einfach
nicht ab macht es einfach nicht und
letztlich die handvoll leute bei dem es
sinnvoll ist dass die die schule
abbrechen
die sind da selber dann zwei davon
überzeugt die würden gar nicht auf mich
die machen es trotzdem bei mir war das
so und das haben auch viele gefragt ich
war in der fünften und sechsten klasse
auf einem gymnasium habe dann
festgestellt gut ich bin viel zu dumm
beziehungsweise viel zu faul trifft er
und hat dann entschieden ab der siebten
klasse runter zu gehen auch die
realschule die aber auch durchgezogen
muss der zehnten klasse hat den raschen
abschluss haben
schmidt von 2,1 oder so also schon
relativ okay so und dann kann man
zumindest in bayern seien aber quasi
nachholen auf einen sogenannten
fachoberschule oder post hat dann quasi
die elfte klasse gemacht und hatte eine
zwölfte klasse gemacht und habe dann
einfach aber wir bekommen das ist kein
allgemeines abitur hat man spezialisiert
sich ja zb mein fall auf technik und
dann sind alle technik fächer holt drei
heftig und ich persönlich würde sagen so
heftig wie auch im gymnasium oder man
muss halt einfach mathe und physik
machen aber dafür ist ein fach englisch
und deutsch und machen sich ein gutes
stück leichter bei diesem fach abi war
es eben so dass ich mir dachte okay
bruder ich mache sowieso das allgemeine
also muss ich dafür jetzt nicht so
heftig viel lernen hauptsache ich werde
dann für die dreizehnte klasse
zugelassen habe ich auch gemacht ich
hatte im jahres- fortgang quasi schon so
gute noten dass sich in der prüfung dann
überall 0 punkte haben wir können um
trotz noch weiterzukommen
dementsprechend habe ich mir nichts
gelernt empfehle ich auch keinen lernt
antwort dafür
und zu dieser zeit war es eben schon so
dass ich ziemlich besessen von dem einen
traum wahr filme zu machen vollzeit
videos zu machen vollzeit effekte zu
machen vollzeit youtube zu machen und
zwar so sehr davon besessen und
überzeugt und motiviert war dass ich
dann die entscheidung getroffen habe
dann zu sagen okay ich mache die 13
klasse nicht fertig und wenn dann
einfach auch nicht mehr hingegangen also
ich habe mich nicht mehr abgemeldet was
echt kacke ist so meldet euch wenigstens
abonniert die schule hatte trotz dem
fachabi so meine zukunft sl fall so
einfach wie in bayern ist echt nicht
schlecht angesehen so damit kannst du
auch technische sachen studieren so ja
nachdem ich dann die schule abgebrochen
habe was diese zeit in der das passiert
ist es war die motiviertesten zeit
meines lebens und das war auch echt eine
komplette achterbahn also das war echt
geil ist es frank also zurückblicken was
ein recht heftig geile und abenteuer
reiche zeit aber es war auch nicht
unfassbar hart und ungewiss und schon so
ein bisschen angst dabei auch wenn ich
komplett davon überzeugt war dass es
klappen kann und mir auch bewusst war
was das risiko ist und ich auch das
risiko in kauf genommen hätte auf jeden
fall in diesem jahr muss ich jetzt nicht
in die hungern oder so da hatte ich
trotzdem glück und support von meinen
eltern ja der rate nicht als euch geben
werde ich werde jetzt nicht sagen
heimmacht
so wie ich es gemacht habe mir jetzt
funktioniert 1 1 weil ich nicht tun denn
ich hatte ziemlich viel glück so viel
glück werden einige von euch nicht haben
und ich war einfach besessen und so
besessen wird kaum einer von euch sein
ich war geisteskrank motiviert und hatte
das glück dass sie schon mit elf jahren
angefangen hat meine skills in diesem
bereich zu üben und deswegen halt auch
schon ziemlich gut war als sie diesen
schritt gegangen bin und das ist
natürlich extrem erforscht und er hat ja
auch einfach glück dass ich dieses
häufig schon sehr früh entdeckt habe
dass es mir eben dann leichter gefallen
ist diesen schritt zu gehen so jetzt ist
es raus wie gesagt projekt die schule
nicht ab bei mir war das ein recht gut
kalkuliertes risiko
das war es mir wirklich wert an der
stelle auf das allgemeine abitur zu
verzichten und der verlust wäre jetzt
auch nicht so heftig gewesen ich hatte
ja immer trotzdem noch einfacher wie
gehabt und eine die zwei drei leute
dieses jahrzehnt für den es auch klappen
würde wenn sie die schule abbrechen
die sind hoffentlich so motiviert dass
sie sich von mir eh nicht abhalten
lassen würden eine frage die keiner
gestellt hat ich habe trotzdem wieder
spannend finde hast du mal einen verweis
bekommen ja und zwar vier stück und der
eine ist megalan weil ich meine
hausaufgaben paar mal vergessen habe
okay der nächste ist der schon witziger
und zwar habe ich da papierkügelchen auf
meine deutschlehrerin geschossen gut ruf
und zwar mit einem katapult was ich
gebaut habe ja aber ich habe sie nicht
absichtlich abgeschossen das wäre echt
böswillig so das wollte ich gar nicht
ich wollte ein bisschen aufmerksamkeit
nah und habe einfach in die gegend
geschossen habe das auto sind getroffen
und das hat natürlich gar nicht gefunden
verständlicherweise und dann hatten die
menschen alles gegeben habe ich auch
verdient und das dritte wahl war
komplett gestört und zwar war ich weil
sie im sportunterricht unfähig
mitzumachen weil mir ein kumpel mit
einem waveboard das ist schon skateboard
für schnitt über einen finger
geschnitten ist und der war dann zur
hälfte durch und man hat es auch gesehen
und ich habe dann zum sportlehrer gesagt
hey bruder ich kann nicht in volleyball
mitmachen tut ein bisschen weh du siehst
hier meinen knochen tut weh
man sagt er so okay sie aber dann
bringen wir doch mal bei der nächsten
stunden attest mit sonst kriegst du
verweist wer hat kein attest mitgebracht
nicht angedacht werden verweis gepflegt
nächste frage bruder erzählen eine
witzige geschichte
da habe ich habe ich nicht eine
geschichte und zwar sehr gute sebastian
man kennt den absolute legende hat mal
zu einer lehrerin gesagt nachdem sie ihm
quasi strafarbeit aufgegeben hat und es
war ein ultra viel das war wirklich
keine humane anzahl an strafzeiten
abschreiben mehr so und dann hat man
auch einfach ausgepackt frau jetzt
können sie mich doch mal am arsch lecken
aber er zeige sitzt er war wirklich
gemacht und alles wieder so handeln
nicht gemacht hat nicht immer aber doch
halt gemacht er hat dann auch ein
verweis gekriegt leute beleidigt eure
lehrer durch das haben sie nicht
verdient aber die gerichte es trotzdem
wird sich die nächste frage und zwar bis
du mal sitzen geblieben nein aber fast
wie gesagt nach der sechsten klasse bin
ich auf eine realschule gewechselt und
zwar fallen die noten nicht so gern
hören denn ich hatte in latein 5,1 und
den paaren anfänger 04 und wer davon
noch mal ne 5 dabei gewesen und welche
dadurch gefallen aber ich habe es
haarscharf geschafft nicht durchzufallen
über geld und deswegen mit der dicken
frage was hältst du vom heutigen
schulsystem das ist gute frage und
letztendlich findet dass das schulsystem
nicht weit davon entfernt ist was es
sein könnte
aber man muss einfach mal sagen so blöde
schulsystem finde es funktioniert es tut
das was es soll es bildet leute dazu aus
für die wirtschaft produktiv zu sein und
ein produktives stabiles land zu
befördern kann man dem schulsystem
einfach lassen wo es natürlich schaltet
ist die leute nicht jetzt irgendwie nur
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich zu machen
sondern auch erfüllt so dass die nicht
nur geld verdient sondern auch glücklich
sind oder zufrieden mit ihrem leben da
und ich glaube das weiß auch jeder dass
die schule nicht dazu da ist dass du
glücklich bist und bedingt auch ein
schwieriges thema weil du kannst ja auch
nicht jeden jetzt zu einem bildhauer
ausbilden weil die die menschheit
braucht halt nur soundsoviel bildhauer
so nah ist ein schwieriges thema aber
ich bin trotzdem schade dass die schule
die kreativität aus den leuten heraus
treibt und die intension system
untergliedert wo die dann einfach lernen
sich untertor in eine der schlimmsten
sachen an schulen ist es dass es junge
kinder dazu zwingen den ganzen tag grund
zu sitzen obwohl die eigentlichen ganzen
tag sich bewegen müssen und ja sie
sollten auch was lernen aber die sollten
sich dann nochmal bewegen und es ist
nicht normal dass junge
und auch nicht erwachsen aber trotzdem
kinder den ganzen tag hinsetzen und sich
nicht bewegen ist auch logisch dass
kinder dann einfach hippelig werden und
sich so nicht konzentrieren können weil
es einfach absolut nicht in ihrer natur
ist ein ganzer grund zu setzen die frage
hat mir auch mega gut gefallen und zwar
kannst du mir nachhilfe geben neben oder
ich kann er nicht nach hilfe geben ich
meine schule jetzt nicht so fleißig aber
ich kann danach in filmen schneiden
geben wenn du nämlich schneiden lernen
möchte es mit premiere pro dann checkt
man meinen schnittkurs ab da bringe ich
dir nämlich bei was man als zum
schneiden braucht und zwar auf gold und
zwar geht der kurs ungefähr zwei stunden
lang und ja man muss nur einmal zahlen
das ist kein abo und der kostet gerade
nur 21 euro und das ist ehrlich gesagt
richtig günstig könnt euch ich meine es
ernst
der kurs ist echt ich stehe voll
dahinter der selbst nice und das
bestätigen auch die leute die das sehen
also kann ich auch einfach mal direkt
herausfordern können durch den kurs
mitschneiden lernen möglich er wird euch
so viel zeit sparen als wird viel
schneller gehen dass ein youtube videos
die euch zusammen zu kommen müsst und
ihr werdet lückenloser lernen und
schneller und auf deutsch und nicht auf
englisch und in der stelle auch mal
vielen dank an alle leute die sich den
kurs schon gekauft haben wir sind echt
viele leute ich nicht damit gerechnet
danke ihr helft mir ich wollte auf
diesem weg der kompletten
selbständigkeit jetzt so das ist richtig
nah ist so auf den eigenen beinen stehen
zu können danke euch klischee aber ist
so und jetzt die letzte frage muss desto
nachsitzen ja ich musste so oft
nachsitzen wirklich aber meistens wegen
hausaufgaben oder irgendwas hälfte
vergessen so kommt also ich habe nie
gegen wegen geschlagen ja habe ich nicht
so ich habe meistens wegen für essen und
hausaufgaben okay leute also könnt euch
mal einen kurs männer schneiden lernen
möchte linke in der beschreibung es gibt
nur noch drei tage 25 prozent rabatt mit
dem kot omar ist also checkt den linken
beschreibung mal ab da findet ihr auch
einen ausführlichen trailer weise noch
ein bisschen ausführlicher drin was
alles da drin steht in den kurs also
könnt euch den trailer mal rein und
folgen wir mal auf instagram rainer
können wir beim nächsten mal mehr auf
fragen stellen und das ist wirklich geil
und dann habe ich ihn einfach mal raus
den spruch wenn ihr mich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte dann abonniert
diesen kanal dann sehen wir uns im
nächsten video wieder macht's gut haut
rein das nächste wie total geil leute
mach's gut und block in der schule
[Musik]